Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
A lot of you asked
what happened to Anakin Skywalker
when he appeared on a soak in the world
between worlds.
Was he a force?
Ghost was a version from the past
during the events of the Clone Wars
Because he was wearing his Clone Wars
armor and he had his Clone Wars haircut.
They also de-aged Hayden Christensen
just a little bit
so that he looked as young
as he would have during the Clone Wars.
a lot of people wondering if he was just
a figment of a Sofia's imagination.
It was all just happening inside
her unconscious mind as opposed to her
traveling into the world between worlds
like we saw Ezra do on Star Wars Rebels.
Just a lot of questions in general.
But in reality,
something much more profound
than just turning into a force
ghost has happened to.
And again
after he died and Return of the Jedi.
So we'll break it all down.
He's something much, much bigger now.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the Ahsoka
episodes.
It's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
we're also doing a giveaway
for the Mandalorian Blu ray.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post all your predictions
for how they're going to use
Anakin Skywalker in the future.
On the video.
this is where the fun begins.
Like, literally, it has just begun.
Hayden
Christensen has just started to come back.
nice if it's like a genuine
sort of recollection of like
I write for them before Buffy.
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on Ahsoka so far.
But during a Soak episode five and again,
Skywalker appears to Ahsoka in
the World Between Worlds
to give her a final lesson.
he looks just like he did
during the Clone Wars.
They were in the world between worlds.
It wasn't meant to be just Ahsoka
imagining
everything like she was in this place.
She really did speak to.
And again, Skywalker, it was real.
And again, as he exists
now in present day.
But choosing to appear
as he did during the Clone Wars.
So it's older and again,
making himself look like he did
when Ahsoka was his young Padawan,
just for the purposes of their lesson.
But it wasn't just force
goes in a can Skywalker talking to her
because we've seen him manifest as a force
ghost before.
We know that he can do that in
it does seem likely
that we'll get another force goes in again
cameos in at some point
but this version of Anakin
that we saw show that he becomes
something way more powerful in way bigger
than just a regular force ghost like Yoda
Obi-Wan Kenobi quite on jinn
in this goes back to Dave Filoni
and George Lucas's Clone Wars Mortis
episodes where he lays out this grander
version of the prophecy of the chosen one
that gets referenced
all the time in Star Wars Normally,
when characters that Anakin Skywalker
was the chosen one, like Obi-Wan
Kenobi, Yoda, even Mace Windu.
Pretty much everyone believed
that he would bring balance to the force
in a more practical kind of way.
The Jedi Council
just thought that that meant
he was super powerful
and would help them kill the Sith,
who at the time they hadn't quite
learned was Emperor Palpatine yet?
Now, according to George Lucas,
at the time, his intent was that
the council was meant to interpret
the prophecy wrong,
and it was the light side that needed
to be balanced back to a more gray
neutral between the dark side
and the light side in the galaxy.
The light that had grown too powerful.
that was George
Lucas's way of justifying order.
66 So and again,
falls of the dark side, Order 66 happens.
Most of the Jedi are either
killed, few survive and scatter
Later,
during the events of the original trilogy,
the idea was that Palpatine
was meant to have grown too powerful.
He fulfills the prophecy again
by killing him during Return of the Jedi.
Then the scales of the force between light
and dark side balance out again
in the galaxy.
But a couple of years
after Revenge of the Sith, when
Dave Filoni and George Lucas
plotted out the Clone Wars Mortis arc,
they made the prophecy about an
it can go even deeper.
Like they add a new context
to the prophecy.
during the Clone Wars Mortis episodes,
they meet the father,
the son and the daughter.
Ancient aliens who are meant
to be so powerful in the force,
it made them functionally immortal.
Each one of them represented
a different aspect of the force.
In the force flowed through them.
Kind of like conduits
to the rest of the galaxy,
the rest of the universe, basically
The sun was like the manifestation,
the conduit of the dark side of the force,
the daughter, the light side in the father
existed to balance out their two powers
so that there was balance
between the light side
in the dark side of the force
throughout the galaxy.
this that was going to be so powerful
that if the sun grew more dominant
in their relationship, the Sith, the dark
side, force users around the galaxy
with the incredible gains in strength
relative to their previous abilities.
In the same for the daughter
with the light side Jedi.
so the mortis gods were kind of like
cosmic amplifiers of the force
conduits through which the force flowed
to the rest of the galaxy
now, because of the Ahsoka series,
we learned about the prettier galaxy.
This effect is also universe wide.
Like, even though we usually just talk
about the one main galaxy.
technically the mortis gods effect
would radiate across the entire universe.
Like the force
isn't just trapped to the one galaxy
the closer the the three of them
were to the main dimension, like the main
universe, the mortal realm
where normal people walk around exist.
The greater their influence on the force.
So he essentially remove them
to the mortis realm,
which I would kind of
like a pocket dimension,
so that their effect on the galaxy
was lessened to a degree
when Anakin meets them, the father
tells him that he's essentially destined
to replace him and become the new balance
between his son and daughter.
That is the true prophecy.
You will bring balance to the force,
but in a more literal way between
these cosmic aspects of the dark side
and the light side I am much more.
And so are you.
you feel your destiny?
You must see it now.
I am dying.
And you must replace me.
But this is yours.
It has been foretold.
The chosen one will remain
to keep my children in balance.
At the time, the father literally wanted
an akin to never leave.
The more to like in this other dimension,
just stay here forever with these other
two members of my family.
but. Essentially
it was the father telling and again
that he was destined to become
another conduit through all force
energy would flow
and he would bring balance to everything.
Then the daughter gets killed by the son.
The father sacrifices his life,
which takes away
the son's immortality, and eventually
he dies, leaving no more mortis.
Gods. But here's the thing.
The father's prophecy about anarchy
and being destined to balance
the force in a more cosmic way
was still going to happen.
now in present day,
Dave Filoni is essentially
bringing all these ideas into live action
from Clone Wars Mortes Star Wars rebels
and paying them off with these
and can Skywalker episodes
in a lot of the other things
that are happening on the show.
this is the way they're explaining
why you haven't seen force goes
and it can appear since Return of the Jedi
is because after his death,
essentially he's replaced the mortis Gods
function in the universe as the balance
between the dark side and the lights.
He's been so busy essentially protecting
the flow of force at a cosmic scale,
he doesn't have time to show up every day
to talk to everybody.
now. For those of you
asking about Luke Skywalker, Anakin
Skywalker's force ghost, we did learn that
after Anaconda died, at some point,
Luke Skywalker met his force ghost
and they had a much longer father son chat
that everyone always wished
that they could see on screen.
Like, wouldn't it be great
to see the two of them talk to each other?
That was meant to happen
while Luke Skywalker was still alive.
After the events of what's happening on
Ahsoka, the Mandalorian
with the Thrawn stuff right now, but long
before the events of the sequel trilogy.
by the events of the sequel trilogy,
old man Luke already knows everything
because he learned it from his father
as a force ghost.
for a brief hot second
Ryan Johnson said that he almost had force
goes and can show up instead of force
goes to pay off a lot of that stuff
but at the time most casual fans
only remembered the events of the movies.
And they just knew
all Luke's time with Yoda
and just felt like their relationship was
closer than his relationship with Luke.
And and again, Skywalker.
maybe someday in the future,
when they do another version
of Luke Skywalker, if it's Deepfake
Luke or they recast the character,
then maybe we can see Luke talk to Force
Ghost and again,
there's also been a lot of cool fanart
and theories
about Asuka's role in all of this
in like the new more disguised
like this depiction of anarchy
and leading the new more disguised
depicting Ahsoka
as the daughter in Starkiller as the son.
But Dave Filoni hasn't introduced
Starkiller formally,
even though there are a lot of theories
about that,
because Sam Witwer is all over
the Ahsoka series in background voices.
but like Ahsoka for instance, has not
become a mortes God or anything like that
on the show when Ahsoka entered the world
between worlds to talk to and again
the reason
why he's able to control the war
between worlds that way,
why he has so much power in
there
is because he's so powerful in the state.
He exists now
more powerful than a normal force ghost
They've only also introduced
a small retcon to the way
the World Between Worlds
works from Star Wars rebels During rebels
he depicted
it is more like a physical location
you travel
to outside the normal dimension.
But on Ahsoka,
the new way of explaining it is
that it's more of a separate dimension.
Your force essence
or your consciousness travels
to while your physical body
remains in the normal realm.
that's how a soldier can enter the world
between worlds.
But her body is still unconscious,
floating in the water.
so it wasn't meant to be a soldier
hallucinating, talking to an again,
she really was talking to him.
It's just that her consciousness
traveled into the world between worlds,
which is more of a metaphysical location.
Now. But essentially
when you're inside the world
between worlds, it works the same way
it did during rebels like it's
connected to all points in time in space.
for example, GROGU
could sit on top of some sort of force
fulcrum
like we saw during the Mandalorian season
two, and meditate his way into the world
between worlds.
But his physical body would still be
sitting on this little perch here it.
Inside the world between worlds,
it still basically works the same.
You're able to access any point in history
or the future anywhere in the universe.
But it also means that
if you wanted to time travel in the war
between worlds,
the only way you could do that
because is your consciousness in the world
between worlds, is it?
You would essentially have to take over
your consciousness in the past,
like your for spirit in the present
would have to take over your body
in the past.
The funny thing about that is it is almost
exactly what Emperor Palpatine does.
He transfers his force essence
to clone bodies when he needs a new one.
for those of you
also asking how Anakin learn
how to become a force ghost
because he died
and we didn't see him get that lesson
with anybody else before he died.
Obi-Wan Kenobi Force
Ghost essentially found his essence
after he died on the Death Star
and taught him how then.
So it was like one force
goes to teaching, another force goes
something Inside the Star Wars universe.
What happens after most people die
Is that your essence, your force Essence
just becomes
part of the greater cosmic force.
Like it sort of disperses into everything
everywhere.
when that happens, you lose all sense of
self, all your memories from before.
Like you basically stop being a person
but the Jedi who learn to become force
goes can retain their consciousness
in sense of self after death.
That's basically
what a force goes is so force
ghost Obi-Wan Kenobi found in essence
after his death, basically taught him
how to become a force ghost before he just
dispersed into everything everywhere
merely theory right now is will price
at least one or two more Anakin
Skywalker
cameos during the Ahsoka episodes
because it's only a couple episodes left,
but they'll be different
types of cameos than the God tier in Akin
that we saw in the world between worlds.
that's archival footage of Anakin
during the Clone Wars
when Thrawn was asking
for Sophia's history
in to learn about her master
because he did know Anakin Skywalker
and also he knew the anarchist
guy worker became Darth Vader.
It actually worked with Darth Vader
on some occasions, end,
I think we'll see at least one
Anakin Skywalker
Force Ghost cameo scene in present day
where like
he just comes to give us a pep talk
before the finale is done.
kind of like a force Goes quick.
On Jin Cameos scene
at the end of the Obi-Wan Kenobi series.
Let me know in the comments.
If Anika is replaced the more as gods,
basically how do you want them to use him
as a character in the movies and shows
that take place way later in the timeline?
Because he can still show up
in like a hundred years
after Grogu has become a Jedi master,
training his own students, giving him sage
wisdom in his current state
and again is effectively immortal,
putting on the panic in costume,
getting to wear those Jedi robes.
It kind of blows your mind every time.
I just feel very grateful.
Hayden
Christensen is also a very young man.
So like he can still come back doing
Star Wars stuff for many, many years.
my full Ahsoka Episode
7 video will post next,
be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for that video I'll update the link
as soon as I post it and click here
for that new Anakin Skywalker Episode
5 Deleted Scene An alternate ending.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!